撮影場所を
上だったんですけど、下に替えました。
俺は気づいてしまったんだ。
なぜ俺は生活と撮影の場所を分けてしまったんだ...
そう
YouTuberたるもの
生活と動画撮影は
生活と動画撮影は切っても切り離せないものなんです。
うん。
なんであの、上はもう完全寝る用の部屋です。
ベッドとカードとポテトチップスしか今置いてないです。
んで下はもう撮影と生活と動画撮影
動画撮影と生活は切り離しちゃだめなんですよ。
そう。
やっぱこの生活感あふれる感じを、俺はね、伝えたい。
髪の毛切りました。
ということで今日は、
外（グサリ）あいたっ...
台風のせいでちょっと気分が悪いからね。
今日はこちらです。
プルルル..パン！
ンフw　ボッコボコやんけｗｗ
自分で作るスーパーボールでございます。
こういういろんなことができますね。
あの、質問コーナーとか、文房具紹介とかも徐々にしていこうと思います。
あのちょっとね、最近バタついてて..あとアニメの見すぎで...
これほんとはね俺ね..　あっ2つ買いました。
ほんとはこれ俺100個くらい買ってまとめて最強の馬鹿でかい自分で作るスーパーボールを作ろうと思ってるんですけど、
お店に2つしかもうなかったのと、
インターネットで買おうと思っても、なんかね、もうね、たぶん、販売が中止になってるんすよ。
そもそも手に入ることが不可能みたいな...
色がちょっとみんな違いますね。
悔しいんですけども...
まあ..たまにはこう庶民的にね、普通に..遊ぼうと思います。
まって..シールが入っている...妖怪シールが入ってるじゃん...
え..結構硬いな
割と..割と硬いぞ。
え..割と.あ..そうか..スーパーボールだからか。スライムではないんだな。
ただ、スライムっぽいっす。でも..あ、取れた。
なんか、あっさり取れました。
すげ～な...
うわ～
ヴェェェェェェェェェwwズｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞ
くそ..これほんとはねマジ100個作ってやりたかったよ..
要するに、これを100個買って組み合わせれば100%できますからね。
割と跳ねるな...
割と跳ねる..
ヴェェェェェェェェェww
ちょっと待って..
こんな殺傷能力感のあるやつなんだ..ちょっ丸くしなきゃ..
まっこれだけ丸かったら絶対大丈夫っしょ..
お～..
お～
お～すげ～
とりあえず..何だろ..どんな形にでもなるスーパーボール的な感じかな？変幻自在だわ。
薄っぺらいです。これもたぶんスーパーボールとしてちゃんと動くはずです...
いや～やっぱこういうね日常的に使ってる部屋の方がやっぱ撮りやすいね動画は。
この2つをじゃあ合わせてみましょう。
あ..でも意外と似た色同士だから..あんまり、こう大きな変化がないから..
ん～割とね..割とちょっとお洒落な色になった気がします。
俺これちょっと保存しとこう..で..なんか..
こういうタイプのスーパーボールちょっと見つけた限り買って、ちょっと頑張って100個集めて絶対いつか作ります。
よし、超丸型です。超丸いです。
お～すごい全然跳ねる
じゃあこれたぶんあれだよ四角、四角ってしたら..
四角くしたらどこで跳ぶかわかんないみたいな新たなね..遊びができるかもしれない...
君たち今まで見たことある？四角いスーパーボールなんて...俺はないね。...むしろボールじゃないけどね。
ボールじゃないけど..四角いスーパー..四角にね...
ちょ..スーパー四角作ってみましょう。
よし..これを投げるともうどこに跳ぶかわかりませんからね。
うわ～～～～コーラ！
うわ～～～～コーラ！コ...
わ..割とマジでヤベェ...
待て..これ洗濯.. これま.台風の日にコーラこぼして洗濯物の服が汚れるっつったらどうやってこの後これを洗濯すればいいんだ...